while we wait with bated breath for
Netflix to release news about an
eventual stranger thing season four
we've collected the information we
already do have along with a few
interesting theories as a way to help
made the uncertainty a little more
manageable the announcement for stranger
things for season came in the form of a
short video teaser which displays the
words stranger things for in the show's
glowing red title fonts as it's eerie
synthesized theme music swells that is
before the dark vines of the upside down
rise - ominously choke out the red light
of the words the teaser finishes with a
card announcing we're not in Hawkins
anymore which could either refer to the
upside down or to the expanded geography
of the show after all the buyers family
did move away from the Indiana town at
the end of season 3 which has teased a
new soviet union based subplot in the
season 3 finale police chief Jim hopper
finds himself dangerously close to the
machine the soviet scientist constructed
to open a gate to the upside down right
as Joyce Byers prepares to destroy it
both Hopper enjoys realized that she has
to do and seconds later the machine
explodes killing them nearby Russian
scientists and presumably hopper as well
but we never see hoppers body either
drawing or after the explosion when
Joyce goes to look at what's left of the
machine there's no trace of him perhaps
he jumped through the gate at the last
second and is now trapped in the
upside-down or maybe he emerged
somewhere else in a season 3 finale
post-credits scene we get a glimpse of a
facility in Russia and the closed door
sealing off a character referred to only
as the American there are a number of
candidates for who the American is but
in an interview with / film David Harbor
who plays sheriff hopper indicated that
he does in fact believe his character is
alive all the way off in the USSR well
Harper is probably the strongest
contender other theories have proposed
that it could actually be dr. Brenner
Billy Hargrove Murray Borman or even a
character we haven't yet met whoever it
is we'll find out for sure in season 4
series co-creator rusty effort on
Entertainment Weekly that the identity
of the American along with the truth of
what the Russians are doing with the
demo gorgon will play a quote huge role
in season 4 the same end credits scene
that seizes the America and also
introduces a fascinating and terrifying
new development to the world of stranger
things the Soviets have a demagogue on
in the scene Russian guards toss a
terrified prisoner into a large metal
cage before turning a crank that
releases the beast from its pen
indicating that they've been keeping at
least one of the creatures in captivity
this may explain why the Soviets were
working to open the gates to the upside
down in the first place
perhaps they've been collecting demagog
ins although for what purpose we can't
be sure the fact that they've been
feeding them humans however suggests are
their motivations are far from
benevolent with the first season of
stranger things taking place in the
winter of 1983 the second in the fall of
1984 and the third in the summer of 1985
some fans are speculating that the
fourth season will be set up in the
spring of 1986 if it is that there's a
possibility that the fourth season will
somehow tie into the Chernobyl nuclear
disaster which occurred on April 26 1986
the Soviet presence in season 3 lends
weight to the theory that we might be
spending more time in the USSR in season
4 while incorporating a deadly real-life
disaster into a series about alternate
dimensions of monsters feels like
precarious grounds there's one
disturbing theory that takes our general
speculation a step further proposing
that it may actually be xi who causes a
disaster either she'll get her powers
back and somehow cool
a new theory action herself or a battle
with the creatures on the upside-down
will have catastrophic repercussions
which will then be swept under the rug
with a story about a nuclear accident
mysterious deaths government cover-ups a
bizarre chemical leak is it all linked
all a vast conspiracy dr. brenner appear
to have died at the end of season 1
season 2 revealed that he survived the
bloody finale and is still out there
somewhere I can help I can find him
however Brenner was nowhere to be found
in season 3 eating fans to wonder what's
become of him since 11 ended season 3
without her powers some fans speculate
that dr. Brennan will be the one to help
her get her abilities back but I'm going
to make you better I'm going to take you
back home
or I can make you well again after all
he's a person who guided her through
developing and holding them in the first
place so it makes a twisted sort of
sensor he might be the key to her
regaining them after being possessed by
the mind flayer for most of season 3
Billy was finally able to resist the
creatures mind-control long enough to
protect 11 from being flayed
unfortunately he was no match for the
giant multi-armed monster and was
impaled multiple times before dying in a
step-sister max's arms however one
theory suggests a billy may have
survived after all and may yet return in
season 4
not only did Billy managed to hold on to
his own body and like most of the mind
flayers victims who've melted before
merging into a single monster but we
don't see what becomes of him after max
goes to his site at the mall it's
possible that someone could have arrived
to save his life just in the nick of
time
if Billy is alive he could be the
mysterious American in Russia what it
seems like a long shot it makes sense
that Russians would take interest in
Billy since their research would surely
benefit from studying one of the few
people who has been taken over by the
mind flayer
and maybe live to tell the tale the 1985
film Back to the Future was a major
pop-culture touchstone for season 3
playing in the movie theater that the
stranger things kids frequent and even
providing amusing conversation fodder
for a drug with truth serum Steve
Harrington and Robin
but perhaps the appearance of a movie
about a time-traveling teenager was
about more than providing a nostalgic
Easter Egg for the audiences and was
actually hinting at future storylines in
a show that was already normalized
concepts like alternate dimensions
monsters possession and telekinesis
time-travel doesn't feel entirely
outside of the realm of possibility for
season 4 it could make a lot of sense
given that time travel was part of the
original concept for the show future
very good and we still understand very
little about the properties of the
upside down or the extent of Elevens
powers it wouldn't be totally
unreasonable to discover that characters
may be able to move back and forth
through time possibly even changing some
of the darker events of the past this
opens up a world of possibilities for
the show maybe we could witness a return
of Bob or Bob newbie and if Hopper and
Billy really are dead time travel may be
the perfect solution to go back and see
them again
while the fictional casting information
hasn't yet been released it's a safe bet
to assume that all of the surviving main
characters will be coming back for
season 4 the buyers family may have
moved but considering they took 11 a
central character and the only one with
superpowers with them it seems unlikely
that they wouldn't return in fact the
buyers move could be a way to open the
storytelling possibilities for the
series Matt defer told Entertainment
Weekly I think the biggest thing that's
going to happen is it's going to open up
a little bit in terms of allowing plot
lines into areas outside of Hawkins
although the duffer's didn't get into
detail regarding which outside areas
they meant we can take a couple of
educated guesses based on season 3 the
first is obviously the Soviet Union but
a third season both began and ended
perhaps whatever strange things happen
in the fourth season will take the
hawking's crew on an adventure abroad
another strong possibility is he as yet
undisclosed town of a pious crew now
calls home although Joyce talked a lot
in season 3 about her family's need for
a fresh start a location of their home
was conspicuously omitted from any of
the dialogue leaving every possibility
open wherever season 4 takes us Frost
tougher says we should expect it to feel
very very different from what's come
before he told Entertainment Weekly but
I think that's the right thing to do and
I think it'll be exciting
before the buyers family and 11 move
away Mike and 11 can
their plans to see each other again Mike
says he's received the OK from his
parents to go stay with the buyers over
Thanksgiving and suggests that perhaps
will and the Levin might return to
Hawkins for Christmas did you talk to
your mom about Thanksgiving yeah yeah
yeah I got the okay I'll be there while
either one of these suggestions could
hint at the timeframe for season for
Thanksgiving seems like the more likely
option since each season is centered
around the holiday and the show already
did Christmas and season one if Mike's
Thanksgiving trip to the buyers new home
is indeed the catalyst for season four
we can probably expect the season to
drop around November 2020 that would
allow 60 months between the release
dates of season 3 and 4 which seems
about right - given the amount of time
between the existing seasons 15 months
between the releases of seasons 1 & 2
and 21 months between 2 & 3
although news of an official renewal
didn't come into the few months after
season 3 that didn't stop the duffer
brothers an executive producer Shawn
Levy from looking ahead while everyone
involved in the production of the show
seemed to be on the same page as far as
taking the story beyond season 3 just
how far they plan on going seems to
still be a little up in the air in an
interview with Collider ahead of season
3 Levy said season 4 is definitely
happening there's very much the
possibility of a season beyond that's
one that's currently undecided
meanwhile the Duffus have said that
while they see the show lasting at least
four seasons and I want to go on for too
long
Ross defer told Entertainment Weekly
like we're going to stretch credibility
it wasn't intended to be a seventh
season thing that would indicate that
the lifespan of stranger things are
somewhere between four and six seasons
with something on the lower side feeling
the most likely but whether season four
proves to be as last or I continues on
for another season or two past that it
sounds as though the duffer's are intent
on ending the show on its own terms
rather than allowing it to overstay its
welcome nearly a year before season 3
appeared on Netflix rumors started
circulating that the third season of
stranger things would be the last for
the duffer brothers a sharona's while it
was sort of a creative duo might still
stay on with the show in some capacity
every important to its overall direction
will be greatly reduced this came as a
blow to fans of the show since the
deficit or the ones who created the
world estranged of things in the first
place losing the toughest at this point
would have robbed the audience of the
opportunity to see the conclusion the
original creators had envisioned
however Netflix quashed a rumor as
definitively as a time hopper stumped on
a skittering peace of mind flayer
the star Court mall the streaming
service tweeted in February 2018 don't
drop your egos rumors that the duffer
brothers are leaving stranger things
after season 3 a false rest assured
we're never stranger things has
eventually draw to a close it will be
with the duffer's at the helm check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and to the bail
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]